are we about ready to go
okay right um good afternoon councillors
and
welcome along to our extraordinary
meeting which is
a deliberative meeting on the long-term
plan and a pretty important one we do
have
a number of apologies we've got an
apology from
council nick grant an apology from
lateness from
councillor brahman reed and and also
uh lateness from richard macphail
richard uh was planning to zoom in but
there's been an airline
hold up this morning so he may get here
and he may not
we'll leave the zoom on just in case he
he does make it
so would somebody like to move those
apologies be sustained please
uh councillor grant thank you signature
council dixon all those in favor please
say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
councillors
right that brings us on to item two
which is the minutes of the
extraordinary meeting when we
heard the submissions from from
submitters
and we have the the minutes of uh
of that meeting uh in your agenda
would somebody like to move that that be
seen as a true and correct record
counselor heisted second to counselor
mcdonnell
are there any alterations required to
that record
do not i'll put the motion all those in
favor please say aye
against the motion is carried
right that brings us on to the uh
substantive
item on the agenda um considering the
analysis of the submissions and making
some decisions around
uh those particular submissions so we
have a report from
the chief executive and i'm just going
to get the chief executive now to give
an introduction to that report and we'll
work through
those items one by one
thanks your worship um yeah my report
uh simply tries to give a summary of the
issues
uh in contention and as i
intimated at the hearing um on the first
of june refrains from submitting a
specific recommendation
but perhaps in some instances i may have
may have dropped
a small hint as to how you might want to
move forward
so these submissions my report covers
the
the written submissions that were
received outside the online environment
and button also includes those
submitters who submitted online
and expressed a wish to be heard and
presented at the hearing on one
june there's a further attachment to my
report
which has been prepared by the
communications manager
mrs sonny gurkhan which give provides
an analysis of the
online submissions received which were
in direct response to questions posed
under
four specific issues and there were
three options contained
within each issue and those uh
issues will need to be determined uh
today as part of the proceedings
and then there's also an attachment from
mr peter standering the roading manager
about roading issues
and tabled with you today
is the my early report on the mountain
road petition
and the except from the council minutes
in may when that petition was considered
with the resolution
being that the petition be treated as a
submission to the ltp so i'll make sure
we cover that off as well
so i'm not sure your intention your
worship but
it might be best to perhaps work through
submission by submission in my report
and then onto the online and then the
roading issues and hopefully that will
encap there's a bit of a discussion
document there
from the chief executive what are your
thoughts counselors
do you want to take any particular
action on this
submission personally i thought they're
doing some really good work
they're reasonably new in our area
there's probably
an opportunity for them to connect a
little bit more with some of the
the social agencies that we have uh
operating in this particular part of the
world
and um and i guess i'm referring to
connecting with community networking
trust a little bit more
and and see where they go from there the
chief executive
talks about um the support councils
given to the
community garden in matera as well on in
the same area
council garden council yeah i think
there's also um
initiative in the calvin church too
doing a community garden
yeah there are a number councillor
bulger
i i think it's really outside of the
orbit of council's
activity to be honest so
look it's good to receive the submission
but
no action for me right so am i
taking it from the tenor so far we
acknowledge
their submission uh and wish them all
the best but we don't intend to
take any part further at this point in
time okay
right um gore and districts and james
there to trust
ah no there's no there's no motion
yeah so gorham districts st james
theatre trust
thoughts from councillors they um they
had some good fortune just right at the
end of that particular meeting where
they received 417 000 which was
was really good they're certainly um
still waiting on another application
what that's going to generate i'm i'm
not sure
uh but they have put a lot of money
together um
to this point in time is it about 1.3
million
which is a you know a really big effort
by a small organisation
so keen to get your thoughts counsellors
council grant
thank you your worship as the council
rep
for seven years on that trust
i'll just yeah i'd like to
reiterate what you've just seen your
worship they have done an amazing
amount of work these guys are volunteers
they keep that place running on a
shoestring budget so there's not money
around
if you uh had a look on the uh
the website of the gore musical theater
you would see that their books
uh stack up they only make about six
thousand dollars a year
i believe the shortfall on the top of
page 37 is actually 236 not 137.
um
but i would be fully supportive of
allocating the shortfall
this shortfall is somewhere between
third was it originally 30 something
thousand dollars in
and 236 000. now now that we've got well
now
the trust has been allocated the money
from the lottery's heritage
but i would be in favor of uh
underwriting that how we underwrite it
that would have to be the chief
executive
and um their administer um
chief financial officer come up with a
some form of plan would be my suggestion
but
okay look thank you councilor grant is
there any other
comments with regard to st james
sitter's trust
councillor bulger if
council was to underwrite that
i suggest it could do so and and there
was a call on
on that role as a guarantor i suggest it
would be done so as a loan
and not converted to a gift or a grant
in some future time
but that would buy the
organisation time to repay that
and if that was the case i would support
it
okay look and i guess i
asked the question a couple of times
what do they mean by an underwrite
um at the submission time and i don't
think i've got a definitive
answer to that but is there any other
comments counselor hosted
yeah i guess just questions around
certainty
we are one step removed and
and we don't have not privy to the
detail on
currency of qs what what if the the
number grows
through tender pricing so i think the
council needs to be of in mind of
like three conditions can we write some
conditions around it to limit that
but are we going to end up back at the
table if the numbers do grow
having to deal with the same issue it
seems like they've tapped out the
the community funding but
being in the context of arts and
heritage and what we invest
in arts as we heard from submitters this
is performing arts
as well as providing a service to
community it does seem that the
council is the founder of last resort so
i think uh i'm leaning towards the
request to underwrite
i don't like the option of the theater
being closed
uh if they're not successful i've looked
at the financials they're doing a
very good job as a group of volunteers
to break even with a small surplus
they don't really have the ability to
repay debt over time
from their operations and a community
funder in my experience doesn't tend to
repay
debt so i'm leaning towards support
thank you um can i just ask the chief
executive put you on the spot if council
was to
um agree to underwrite uh this amount
how would you see that whether it be the
mechanics of that
how would it work it depends your
worship on
what quantum you're exposed to uh and
i've just
taken on board council doug grant's
comments that he thought that the
shortfall was more 236
for some reason i calculated 137 but
that was on the fly with
at the hearing i
have talked to laurnae our chief
financial officer about this our view
was that
um we could we could
um you with with working capital we
could
uh underwrite somewhere around about
that 200
grand mark and
if further applications of funding came
through
great if there was then a residual
amount left over after six twelve months
then there would be a small loan or
or rating whatever it would do to to mop
it up
and so i came to the meeting today
thinking that you might want to
qualify your underwriting to a certain
level
and that will actually bring it will
force the trust to either
come back to the council say well we're
over what do we do
or do we change the scope of the project
but
i'd be a little uncomfortable just
saying the council
underwrite without a qualification about
quantum
so that we and then and also all
ratepayers know what
the potential exposure is and if it's
greater than that you've got a chance to
have a further
conversation with the trust and make an
informed decision at that time
thank you steve um stu
did you want to make a comment yeah i
agree with the chief executive
on uh we've got to set a limit around it
yvonne bannerman contacted me yesterday
and talked to me about this project and
they're
talking to her there are some options
within the project like the little
theater doesn't
doesn't have to be done up at this time
so they've got some room
to maneuver so i think if we sit set a
reasonable
figure is our underwriting limit and
then
if there's further things they can come
back to us but they've got options to
trim their budget they also don't know
whether they're getting that 99 000 from
the ttcf
so there's a whole lot of things up in
the air they don't actually know
until they put them out to tender what
their
tenders are so i think we need to be
give them support but qualify
the way that she said put a top number
on it and they have to come back and
talk it through with us because we're
not
the people directly in contact with
people okay so
what i'm hearing from around the council
table is that there is support
for this particular application but
there needs to be some quite strict
parameters around
the level of the under right does
anybody
have a motion in mind that they would
like to suggest
just a suggestion as you know with the
grants we've granted them sixty thousand
dollars
and to support this project going
forward
you'd have to probably grant twenty five
thousand a year to to
write off the loan because i don't think
you're gonna find any cash coming back
so they would sort of tell them in 10
years they'll get no money
from council until it's paid off
and so you basically committing to about
25 000 a year
unless they pick up this other 99 000.
and quantify the number to 236 000
um and hopefully we don't have to come
up with that hopefully they get the
other funding of 99
000 here so you're suggesting that
uh a quantum be 236 and it'd be um
be an underwrite yeah until they know
definitely what they
require definitely alone yeah council
bolted did you
well this this is the pivotal question
you know is is it a
grant is it a loan that's
granted over time over 10 years or
whatever
or is it alone there has to be some
effort
from the trust and and i accept that
they
they don't have huge resources but there
has to be
some effort or some demonstration that
they will
impart or fall um return
some of that money not to us to the
right parts and
you know i i it's just so easy and look
there are worthy calls absolutely
no question about that they're really
cool
but we once again find ourselves put in
a position
where we're doing great things but with
other people's money and i'm i'm
reluctant to do that and that's where i
think alone is the appropriate mechanism
and you know there's got to be some
discussion out of
can it be paid back is there some effort
to some degree
even even if it's a token effort that's
where i
that's my opinion okay
council chief executive you wish i
always wonder whether
we can take this issue in two bites
to avoid a protracted debate
i wonder whether you first just
addressed the issue
of underwriting and to what limit
and then secondly once you know what the
residual gap is
then you address the question as to how
you fund that
and what commitment you would expect
from the trust to make
so there are two separate issues in my
view and i guess we're not going to know
that
residual value until they complete their
applications to
various funders um dennis
um yes through your worship i understand
that there are two different
identities that you have the the trust
and you have that only looks after the
facility
and then the operation side of it is
looked after by another group
so there's probably no funding coming
through
from leasing the properties
that's coming back to the trust it's all
going to the operations group
so i'm just wondering how they would
finance
a loan it would they'd need to apply for
more funding
from other organizations yeah we have
been here before
and and it's pretty pretty important
that we get this
clear and concise today so everybody
understands both
everyone around the table but also uh
some james sitters trust
and and indeed that community so i've
got i quite
like the chief executive's idea of
quantifying
air support and to what level and then
work out where we go
from there council grant
thank you worship this
the council is one of the trust members
there's four people in this
and and we've all heard the submission
it was a very good submission
they don't have the facilities to be
alone and as
as as worshipers just said we've been
here before we were
here two years ago when we had
and we were here um when they had a fly
lone tower
same thing this is an integral part of
the community
now the arts and heritage
is funded by this council
so there's no reason why this that this
sin james theatre is not
here coming and getting money
all the time every year they are just
they run their own ship
they're volunteers we all know that so
this is my soapbox a little
little stand here at the moment tracy
but
we we know that if we don't do something
and they can't get this across the line
that theater
has real possibility of closing so
um talking about loans and things the
thing
is doesn't it cannot
produce enough money to do a loan so
this is underwriting
is basically getting the council to back
them
and get the building finished and fixed
so it's got a lift and it
operational and
that's basically me look okay um
just thank you doug and just going back
one step
um is there support around the table uh
for and under right to uh
a certain figure to a certain level
there appears to be
what is that level
counselor high stake well your it has to
be enabling so the trust is short
two hundred and thirty seven thirty
seven thousand so it has to be that
but i agree with the concept they're
taking in two bites but we also have to
have our feet on the ground
and understand when we underwrite if
we're not going to put any parameters
around it now
we face the risk of having a
grant or a non-reparable loan to the to
the uh
trust for a period to be grant away so
i just think there's benefits of moving
the meeting forward in that way
but we've all got to clearly understand
what we're committing to and i'm
comfortable with that
okay so is there anybody around the
table who doesn't agree
that we underwrite this particular
request to 237 maximum
and we'll know more what that looks like
once the granting applications have
been exhausted
okay so let's accept that so
is this a grant or is this a loan
counselor hosted i'm concerned that the
wording of loan will not
enable the trust to seek or grant or
enable the trust to seek
additional funding the minute the
council fills that gap
um community funding dries up so
yeah secondly that's where the concept
of underwrite and the interim
was valid so
do we need to take that second step at
this point
is it beneficial to take that step
counselor accounts for bulger and then
council reed
i'd be reluctant to take that second
step i know where were heading
i know we were heading i just wouldn't
want to deny the trust the opportunity
to
return um some of that loan monies to
the council
right you know and i'm look i'm sure
here on the heart they
they will if they can i know i know it's
a big ask but
yeah fully supportive um and i know
we're probably eating
counselor read thank you your worship
apologies for likeness
um i think we also need to remember that
our council is one of the very few
councils in the country who does not
support
um the theatre and the arts and as
councillor grant said we do support arts
and heritage
personally i'd like to see us make a
grant and possibly
split over 10 years 25 000 a year
but because as councillor heisted also
said if we make
them alone that will actually preclude
them being
eligible for a lot of funding so i think
we need to step very carefully here
council davis yeah without without the
lift
there is no theta basically because they
can't operate
and they have to have a lift now it's in
and our council has said that
that they have to have a lift so we're
in a catch-22 we're dictating the rules
and yet we're holding back the money so
um i think underwriting is the way to go
and but i think we need some some rules
around
around that parameters if you like
so
yeah worship i think um
the this it pays to remind yourselves
what the submitter has asked for the
submitter has asked for
the council to underwrite history has
taught us that
sometimes when the other party isn't
present and we impose
uh terms and conditions it can come back
to haunt us
and that's what happened back back in
2007 2008 the fly tower where the
council
the submitter asked for a grant it got
an interest-free loan
um at the deliberative meeting and then
five years down the track they said look
we can't pay back and we were never
privy to the discussion to actually
agree to a loan the first instance
so that coupled with unknown
uh funding applications that could be
successful
and the unknown final tendered price of
the successful contractor
leads me to think that at this point in
time all you need to do is to
to agree to underwrite to a certain
value
and then further dialogue can take place
with a submitter about
any modifications to that and what it
might mean in terms of what is
the gap what is their contribution and
what is the council's contribution
because underwriting is just to
enable the project to proceed with
confidence
it's not actually the ultimate financial
instrument that might be
executed once all costs are known
okay look that makes sense to me so
unless there's another direction council
wants to take would somebody like to
move
along those lines council council davis
and secondary councillor grant thank you
so the motion is that we underwrite
a loan to the st james theatre trust oh
sorry un underwrite
the request from the st james said trust
to shortfall
your worship underwrite the shortfall in
the short ball
i think worship is you underwrite to any
shortfall to
a maximum amount of 237 000. that's
right
thank you for that clarity okay um
i'm going to put that motion all those
in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
councils
right um public health south and we had
uh
quite an exhaustive submission
uh from from them largely supportive is
there any action
required by council at this stage
don't think so okay thank you um
okanowi mountain bike club and we have
uh
another good cause
bringing some real value to our
community asking for
financial support and the club has
requested the council grant
25 000 a year commencing from
22 23 year to on
to help out with their maintenance and
development costs
of the tracks that they're undertaking
so
councillor's thoughts on this
who's going to be for scleros um
i'm really supportive of the hokunui
bikers and what they're doing
but what i would like to see them is to
have a feasibility study
and an ecological study because they are
doing work
they would like to do further work
around donald park
and i think a lot of the trail is on doc
glenn so i'm
wondering where their responsibility is
to assist with
funding and i know there's a community
fund
that doc has annually
for projects like this on scenic reserve
land
i'd be happy to assist them in filling
out a funding application of
for that if that was necessary um and i
also know that um through the predator
no jobs for maha that they are getting
funding through there to do some weed
control
on the trails so
although i really do support it i really
think that to
have some more development they
they need to do a feasibility study
which would include their ecological
study and
and the economic report needed because
we don't know how many
numbers of people are using the track we
have no idea about
what it could bring into the community
and to
apply for other funding maybe government
funding or to other departments they
would need to have a
really solid feasibility study i believe
look um thank you counselor um
dixon i i think if this was the first
application we'd had from hokkaido
bikers club i'd be agreeing with with
what you're saying
i think that we're fair way down the
track excuse the pun
at this point in time uh and there is a
apparently a good relationship now with
doc and
hawking bikers which hasn't always been
the case
i thought they provided a a compelling
argument at the submission time and
and i guess i'm in a position now where
i i'd be
happy to support the application
understand exactly what you're saying
and if this was the first time we'd
heard from them
i would be agreeing with it but it's not
so any other comments counselor bulge
you want to make a comment
that the initial track building and
would require consent and there would
have been
uh requirements for an ecological study
and and that background work
particularly when they're associated
with docs so
i just wonder if that's not already
completed work i'm
asking the chief executive i guess
i don't want to put people to a needless
experience
i through your worship i couldn't really
answer that categorically
um i can only endorse what his worship
has said about it's a lot closer working
relationship
um between the hogan bikers group
and doc but there's there's no
um reason to not to be able to embrace
council dixon's suggestion and that
could be that you may want to
if you are of a mind to grant make an
annual grant as suggested
that you may want to include
the caveat that the funding
should not just go on develop
maintenance but uh
on any feasibility study that may be
required any project
uh or any environmental impact
assessments
and such like so that's all part of
a a responsible bikers
club's expenditure moving forward
and you might want to embrace that in
any
decision you make but i can't give you
an absolute um response on the accuracy
of
what they've done with doc and whether
it's actually
uh whether they've complied with any
requirements around feasibility study
okay um councilor
phillips thank you worship i i see that
in this submission
that they've actually got three projects
going at the same time
uh reby road hamilton park and also
donald park do we as a council set a
priority on
on which ones to that we want the money
to go to um
like as our priority to get ribby road
up and running so that
the residents of of the district can
ride from
gore to dynamo park or where's our
priority do we just give them the money
and say
spend half here and a half there but you
know i think we need to
think about where we're going to put the
money to and what's
what is our priority
councillor um hosted then councillor
gardon
you thank you russia um
we it's not just about there's neville's
head it's not just about dollar more
park there's the delamar park
uh the um conservation land rebbe road
hamilton park and walnut grove so
we're not just in dock area and there's
i really take my head off to this group
because in my time in council i think
it's
one of the few that have actually put
some real
um assets for the community for the
young people
on the on the ground and it does serve
middle age and youth through the through
the end of ebooks
cycling is exploding nationwide
worldwide
and and we're not sent to otago and
we're not attracting that government
funding maybe maybe we're all
in time but currently we're not and
this is just a small way that we can
secure the assets that that we have
the the the bush track for example is
has been assessed by dockers i
understand it is meeting their standard
off track
if you ride that track you'll be covered
from head to toe and mud
doc don't require the to be graveled um
to make it an all-weather trap the
amenity value for tourism and
people in the district is to go for a
ride and not you know not get absolutely
filthy so
to me that that budget provides
assistance probably in the parks and
reserves area that's been
been happening in behind the scenes and
make good now so
the suggestion that it that's made in
the report that it formed some for
some part of the parks and reserve
budget with
with some qualifications i'd like to see
that
the informal group meetings that we've
had have some some influence on that and
we will bring doc into those meetings
and and ensure that um the relationship
is good so
to me it's it is a club it's their
organization we just need to be a little
careful we don't
try and dominate it allow them to work
at their own pace
with some assistance and grow what's on
the ground now
thank you counselor got on yeah i just
wanted
we would like to have seen a budget on i
like
last time they came to us they wanted 30
000 and i think it
they didn't actually burn the money for
about three years but there was some
holdups and um
we're going with 25 000 just up front
there's no budget here or hell
no plan which neville was saying and i'd
like to see more of a plan and see if it
actually
is completed in year one than just
wholesale 25 000 a year
year on year on when sometimes it may
not be completed
with volunteer work so we may not be
you know physically with our 30 000 we
didn't see it all burnt
in one year and they were asking for 25
000 was
continuous back then and this time
around
it's quite good to see a plan and see a
budget of where the money will go and
what they're going to concentrate on
first and complete
well i understand exactly what he's
saying and instead right i guess
there's two aspects to this in that
they're asking for
um maintenance funding and also
development funding and i guess in the
in the early stages most of it's going
to be development and then as time goes
on
the priority will shift to uh to
maintenance
councillor heisted you're going to yeah
just in response that that that's why i
like the concept of a budget line within
the parks and reserve budget
that that the disjoint informal group of
council club members
and doc can have some influence on how
it's spent it's not
handing twenty five thousand dollars a
year to the club
unbudgeted there need to be a business
case as to what it's for
doesn't make sense and you know doesn't
maintain a red value that that's the
concept that i've got in my head and
probably not quite what the
club's got to mine but i think it's a
pretty good um middle ground
okay john it could have could it be
squeezed out of the parks reserves about
it
do you want to answer that
uh well not really off top of my head
you worship i mean i've
the part i mean people some people say
parks reserves
it's a big budget and look it is but uh
previous councils have had working
parties and look at
efficiencies within the area but you
need to
appreciate how extensive our parks and
reserves are
and there's a high degree of cost of
maintaining what
what i really uh is probably this
community's point of difference compared
to most
so i don't want to be put into position
where i just say yeah we'll grab it out
of 20
out of past reserves we could but it's
probably going to be at the expense of
something else
um so i'd prefer if you were
to make that call that i could at least
go away and research and come back to
you with
how it might be able to be financed and
what the impact might be
i guess that's a nice way of saying no
counselor bulger
um i've been involved in probably about
three of those reviews of parks and
reserves budgets
and every time um we undertook
a review with an aim of reducing spanish
we found a whole lot of areas that were
underfunded
and in
even after review we we still weren't
able to fully fund what was required so
is there is there um some spare money in
the parks under his budget
i could guarantee there won't be uh
and so this has to be a separate item um
look these guys are producing an asset
i guess you know 25 25 000 we're taking
it off right past but these
these guys are producing an asset we're
getting something
uh for it and um
it's a promotional thing um not only for
the people
of the district but also people coming
to the district so
worth your support and no i don't have a
bicycle
i don't ride you could have um
council davis you think your worship
i support it and i support council
heisted's
view that it should be part of the parks
and reserves budget
with with input from from the working
party one of the things i think i would
like to see
and richard pascoe when he presented to
us said he actually didn't know because
they hadn't been able to do the work
would be to know the numbers so if we
can
maybe make that a priority for one of
their first rounds
so that we've got a count of how many
people are actually using the track
because
i think they need that information if
they're going to look at further funding
anyway
that's right thank you good point okay
so
i think we've got a reasonable
understanding around the table where
council sits
would somebody like to move in that
direction
councilor phillips thank you driver
signature for that
council grant thank you so
um
so we are um agreeing to their request
uh and that it be um domiciled within
the parks and reserve budget
and that we're asking them to as soon as
possible provide us with the numbers of
users
on the track
yep yeah and a working party between the
two
entities be formed okay i'm going to put
that motion all those in favor please
say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
right um item five sport southend and we
have a submission
uh from port south and looking for some
financial support from this council to
work with the
the other councils in the in the region
to implement a regional spaces and
places strategy
um okay open for discussion
councillors
counselor bulger i thought we'd already
agreed um
to uh uh support the suttas
no yeah we would at a recent meeting we
agreed to support it
but we didn't actually stimulate um
okay that's right we're good like that
counselor hosted just a question i
probably should have asked it last night
and maybe it was do we know where the
other council sit
in terms of their funding support sorry
to put in the spot steve
i understand invercargill have uh
supported it i'm not too sure about
south and district that's why i
put the comments in my report but i did
yeah south south district haven't yet
considered the
long-term plan
okay thoughts from councillors
personally i support it i think that
it's um it's a good thing for us to be
working collaboratively as a region
particularly in these high cost
but also high use areas regional sport
is
is gaining a lot of traction you only
need to go out it doesn't matter what
day of the week you go out you see
a lot of these particularly big um
resource uh consuming entities being
used uh to their maximum so
sharing our resources to to get the best
result i think is the right thing i
think sports southampton have
um delivered in the past and
and i've got no doubt that they will
deliver into the future
somebody like to move a direction in
that one
yeah okay okay
so move councillor bulger that we
support this to have a secondary
yeah that's right that everybody's in or
nobody's in
that's right yeah yeah okay
uh i'll put that uh motion all those in
favor please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
councillors
item six uh croydon aviation trust
and we have a submission from crorden
aviation trust
um and it's recommended that council
approve in principle
the explanation of a closer working
relationship
with the trust um
and to work out where to uh for the
future
does anybody want to speak to this
particular item
or move a direction
your worship i should probably declare
an interest at this point yeah look i'm
happy that you declare the interests and
you can still talk if you want to
everybody understands the connection
sure um
yeah look i think um like i sit uh
around the table
uh supporting um my employer
mr talek and there is there certainly
seems to be a mood at the table to
to engage with council and explore um
the future relationship and and mr
davidson watts is
dr davidson watts has captured that in a
submission
and yeah i think it's a good opportunity
for the council to
align themselves with gordon it's it's
uh
it's uh it's on all our promotional
material it's it's one of our gems
so i think it's in our best interest to
explore as best we can
and there's no request for funding at
this stage
so council bulger council read council
dixon
um look at yes it's a significant
activity in air district it's it's a
one-off it's something that's
unique to this area and other other
districts don't have we should be
involved
i i know there's been
because it's such a complex setup
there's been challenges
as to how one may or may run it and
who's responsible and
who can be involved but obviously
somewhere along the line there will be a
call for some
uh support which is probably in the way
of finance
and i think when that time comes we
should consider it seriously
unless we're involved at this stage and
understand how that activity
operates we won't be able to understand
how we would
best contribute either financially or in
kind so i i definitely support it
councillor thank you your worship
i think you only have to be out there
not only through
weekday weekends but weekdays there's
always a continuous stream of visitors
and i mean unfortunately councillor
heister took the words out of my mouth
at this stage there is no money involved
so you know
we've got nothing to lose i'd like to
see us definitely
work closer with them and just see
exactly where that will
lead great council dixon
thank you worship yes i agree i think
it's um
it needs to be included under the arts
and heritage
um area for for gore
and um i just give it my support because
there is a future there um and we need
to be investigating that
okay uh it appears there is no dissent
to sending voices on this one and it's
that's good to hear
so um the recommendation i guess would
be along the lines that council
approve in principle uh the exploration
of a closer working relationship with
crorden aviation
heritage trust and
step through that process and get to a
point where
we can both work to the end of
developing
a resource that is going to be useful
for the district and also for the
entities
out there somebody like to move along
those lines
so move council davis second to council
read thank you
now put that motion all those in favor
please say aye against the motion is
carried
right item seven um heritage new zealand
and largely supportive submission from
them
um but they've made the suggestion that
we probably
should consider a targeted rate for
seismic strengthening
and i think we have been in that
position before so
i'm not sure that there is a will within
the community to
to go down that track but i'm open for
discussion on that one so councillors do
you have any thoughts know i think it's
been expressed in the past that most
people were not very willing to go there
because some have and some haven't
and um it's going to be a problem though
in the future
it's something we need to think about
because probably
we maybe landed with some of these
buildings with brake powers paying no
rights
when they have to actually evacuate the
buildings
there has to be some we need to probably
think about it and have a
bit of a dig probably but whether we
jump into
having a fund any mechanism i'm not sure
i'll vote against everything
so you think we need to think about it
it's not time right now
is that what you're saying um okay any
other thoughts
counselor heisted thanks richard i i
just think that
the quantum of the fun required to have
any meaningful
impact in this area was probably one of
the reasons that
it didn't didn't gain support in the
past so
i don't i don't believe the view of the
community has changed
okay council belgium
typically it's become my my habit to say
what i think other people are thinking
um look great idea heritage building
wonderful
fantastic until you get to the pointy
end where you ask those people who
who appreciate those buildings how much
will you put in
and generally there's stunned silence
as they come back to you and say well
somebody else can do it the rate payer
or a targeted rate or whatever
so no you know laudable
appreciation of um all things of a
heritage valley but
you know we can't fund it i'm not happy
to fund it
by targeted right okay look i i
get the tenor around the table and and
understand that because we have been
here before
okay is there anything further we need
to discuss with regard to
new zealand heritage there's not we'll
move on then to
um hakanu runanga
and we have a largely supportive
submission from
okano runanga which reflects
the relationship that we've developed
over the last two or three years
particularly
but i would have to say that as that
relationship
is developed it's also shown
a few gaps in our understanding and
appreciation
of their role and function
in our community and certainly from an
individual perspective
i've learned that i need to know a whole
lot more about how
the ewe world works
and and to inform me um about my
role as a as a partner uh with ewe
and and i think the suggestions that
have been made in this
particular submission are worthy of
consideration
for us as a council both councillors
around the table but also
as an organisation to to better
understand the cultural aspects of
that relationship but it is open for
discussion
council reed thank you your worship
um i remember a few years ago we
actually had a training well
training day into chinese heritage
and and also their culture and how we
should be dealing and speaking with
them and and i just think this is a
no-brainer
um we just need to step up and get on
with it
in my opinion totally agree
okay any other comments
yeah counselor heisted then councilman
yeah look i'm supportive in terms of the
training but i was just wondering in
terms of our existing
training budget is there
without providing additional budget is
there any room for re-prioritizing
within our existing budget level because
we have quietly
tripped up in a number of areas during
the discussions today
through your worship the training budget
was cut quite considerably
last year in response to covert to get
that 2.84
i'll need to confer with chief financial
officers to where
it currently is at but it is quite
modest to be honest for an
organizational
provision and hence the suggestion of
like and 20 was just my wild
guess as to what it might take but when
you're talking about an organizational
wide response
you need to have a reasonable amount of
money to get
people through some basic training in
courses
so
i don't know whether you could nibble
too much off that but
look don't know do you want to make any
kind about the training budget and
for the coming year versus what we had
last year
thank you uh chief executive and your
worship uh
our current budget for training is very
very minimal for the whole organisation
it's probably under 10
000 so this is more than doubling our
current training budget
councilman councillor dixon councillor
davis
bret councillor heisted just asked the
question that i was
going to ask and i think your training
budget at 10 000 is actually extremely
light normalization of the size
oh that's all i'd say
counselor um davis
yeah councillor dixon sorry
i'm just wondering if this is the
opportunity to join with other
organizations because i have heard out
there there's quite a few
different organizations that would like
this sort of training
so that could assist with our budget
yeah that's entirely possible i guess we
we do need to have um some local
government specific
uh focus but wider yeah look i think
i'm up for that council davis
thank you bishop i was just going to ask
if you've got any idea how much
we might need to put aside for this um
any ideas
twenty thousand does that which yeah
twenty thousand
okay
so where are we going on this
councillors do i have a direction or
somebody prepared to move a motion that
we support this
move councillor matanow secretary
councillor davis thank you
that we support the recommendation that
we put aside a sum of twenty thousand
dollars
in the training budget uh for the
specific purpose of undertaking
cultural competence for both elected
members
and council management at this point
i'll put that motion all those in favor
please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
right item 9 hospitality southland
south and hospitality new zealand
submission
is there anything that we need to be
responding to on this one
okay no no we move on then um
item 10 new zealand memorial museum
trust
uh league winner i really struggle with
that
name how do you pronounce it
yeah that's right so um
this has been um a long-standing request
um it has been a cause that
invercargill city and particularly the
mayor of invercargill city took up
some years ago um but to this point in
time
we have um resisted being part of it
is there a desire around the council
table to
change that direction it doesn't appear
to be
so we'll move on
um regional tourism new zealand
is there any um
any specific response required from
council on this one
no okay um claire welsh
expresses concern about the
accessibility difficulties and public
safety
associated with access to hamilton park
which has been something that's been on
our radar for some time
and recommending that council enter into
negotiations with nzta
or the view to putting planning in place
for a major overhaul
of how our pedestrians and cyclists and
drivers
can access hamilton park in a in a safer
manner
is there any disagreement with that
direction
not disagreement worship but probably
something a little bit more urgent
around immediacy
of speed limit reduction uh rather than
being on a waiting for the next three
year cycle to get this across the line i
think they're
this is this has been on our radar for
three years but we haven't managed to
actually make any traditions so
if we can explore some interim solutions
depending on a long-term solution that
would be
so i guess our engagement will be with
nzta or
kotahi around long-term funding
long-term options but also immediate
options as well so it is the same
same entity we're dealing with there's
none yeah
uh council garden yeah we should still
um
push our about trying to progress this
because basically
they'll have a whole list and they're
falling behind but this does come into
another category
as walking and cycling and that funding
that they've sent up
may tick this this box so
it's probably worth another push
especially the letter we got the other
day
we have another have another go this one
and you never know they might have been
clinking their arm or that we might just
niche through they might feel sorry for
us too yeah
okay um right
somebody like to move that we um go down
that track
counselor uh grant second to councillor
reid
that we uh undertake uh negotiations
with
waka kotahi to
to ensure that access to hamilton park
is safer for all users
in the future put that motion all those
in favor please say aye
aye against the motions kerry sorry to
read
that council read just reiterating what
councillor hai stead though about
immediately looking at reducing that
speed
south and federated farmers
so is there any direction required
from this one i think um there's some
comment from
chief financial officer in the response
here do you want to
say anything any further on that one
lornae
no okay counselors see if we got any
any further comments there's not right
we'll move on to
um item 14 sally mcintyre
is there any direction um that we need
to take on this one
particularly any recommendation
counselor guarding
i think it's uh we haven't missed out
seeing the um race break down in our
right notices and
it's good to see that's going to come
back yeah
okay so we'll note that uh
item 15 q guard item
right is there any action required from
councillors on that council guideline
i i think i've seen a report that there
is some action going to happen
on the roading system from peter and um
so this is going to be move forward so
and i think we've been
we've seen the roads this is you're
talking about railroading
yeah yeah yeah yeah i'd have to say
there is
some need of maintenance there
uh okay
this is a an issue that has raised its
head from time to time
over the years and we seem to get into a
good state and then it
we go backwards into uh into an area
where the roads aren't quite as good as
they have been in the past
is there any thought around the council
table that it would be useful
for a small working party of
staff and councillors to to meet on a
reasonably regular basis
just to discuss the challenges and the
opportunities within
our roading network both rural and urban
council against the ground
thank you you worship um yeah i i
actually believe
you're right i think we should have a
small working party uh we have had a
change
of uh in the last few years change of
contractors
and uh all of a sudden they go
do a marvelous job at the start and then
somehow uh
you might change a greater driver or
whatever and then all of a sudden it's a
different sort of scenario
it's possibly uh part of you know some
of the fault
probably lies possibly lies with us with
funding of putting
the gravel on the road but anyway a
small working party including the arab
and then rule would be a
perfect idea okay so you're moving in
that direction
i'll move that direction your worship
all right dive a second after that
councillor davis thank you
uh i'll put that motion all those in
favor please say aye against emotions
carried counselor
dixon do you want to make a comment i
just want to say that i noticed on the
survey that since 2015 the
um the graph has gone
down with the communities acceptance of
gravel roads and urban roads and i was
wondering what happened
from that time is that when we changed
contractors
or
um look i
without having in front of me i'm not
sure um
but i know that when the contract was
changed
there was um quite a lot of very
positive comment
came from particularly the rural area
there wasn't a lot of
noticeable change in the urban area so
something's changed since then i'm not
sure
right we'll move on then to item 16 and
chris smith
no operational comment required is there
any comment counselors would like to
add to that it's not okay
um gore rural ratepayers group and we
have a submission
covers a number of um aspects of council
operation
is there any further comment required
there
council davis just on because we had a
couple of submitters that
were adamant we should go under the
river or dig a trench through the river
and just put pipe in or digging a trench
in the river won't be
at all acceptable with environment south
and so that's
that's a no-go and to dig under the
uh river we did look at this as a
council very thoroughly and we went and
looked at mvm's operation out the road
and we spent
months looking at whether we should do
it and we're almost on the point of
doing it
when mvm got their final bill and then
we thought
maybe we won't because the their initial
bill
trebled from what they thought it was
going to be so
i don't want we might be lucky if we did
drill under we might have a clean run we
might
do it you know at a reasonable cost but
chances are
from what nvm experience we won't and
i'll end up blowing out to
an enormous amount of money so i felt
like saying that at the time of the
hearing but
i felt it had been covered before but
just for the sake of
finality i just wanted to say it today
fair enough so thank you
okay all right um no other response
required
right um benny mcmanus
any particular comment required
and i i guess what i'm saying no further
comment required
all these submitters will be thanked for
their for their submission
uh councillor bulger yeah i did enjoy
reading eddie's um
submission about what he thought was
wrong with the reef and
he'd done some roofing and certainly
while he was an apprentice and i thought
he probably knew what he was talking
about
no question about that so i did
appreciate that
um but notwithstanding that um
you know that that that old library
building is
no longer the best option for us but it
was
it was it was good to get a submission
from an older gentleman who knew what he
was talking about when it came to
the ins and outs of how roofs are made
to be uh weather type
are you insinuating an older gentleman
don't know what they're talking about
no i i just the opposite actually your
worship
possibly they're getting a little bit
deaf though as i am myself
right okay um
thank you um yeah like um councillor
bulger
i did uh enjoy uh mr mcmanus's
submission
and as people are aware around the table
that i
in an agreement with them that we are
too big
for council and we need to reduce our
numbers and we should probably look at
that
councilors you mean sorry councillors
yes
yeah okay and
every six years we get the opportunity
to to make our suggestions
to the commission that deal with that
particular issue
item 19 hamish makai
is there any further submission there no
uh in cupit
certainly knowing's views on a number of
items um
is there any further comment required
there it's not
jack macintyre
uh adam newton
um councillor phillips
thank you yeah once again um i um
listened to adam and what he had to say
in regards to the buildings
and i probably disagree with them about
building up because
most of their um residents are getting
older they don't want to be climbing
stairs
and and certainly like i think
it was good that adam came along and and
told us what he thought
um but the the idea that there hadn't
been any brownfields
uh infill and gauze is not right
um there's been a whole lot of
redevelopment on particularly quarter
acre sections that have been
divided up into three or four and a
number of units put on those so
look i value this submission um
but i don't particularly think that's a
priority right this minute
okay
that brings us to the end i think of is
there any other submissions
that require a particular comment from
counsellors that we haven't
included in that that list
before we move on to the online
submissions
council guideline yeah i just wanted
some
there's a lot of um hearsay thinking
about what it's going to cost for our
bridge in our water pipes
and um and what a treatment plant
once we finalize tenders which may take
longer now than we thought
we need to sort of publish those out
there so that
they can actually see them for
themselves but we can't really do that
too
yeah for a while yet but i mean it does
need to be put out there what it's
actually going to cost and
broken down so some of these people can
work through the numbers
that's right and i guess there's an
appeal process that we've got to work
through as well
so it does take some time
and resource to do that
okay if we move on then to um analysis
of the 10-year plan uh that has come in
through alex
talk platform uh
and on on hard copy and we have a
breakdown here
that i think the communications manager
has put together
um do you want to make any comment to
those sonia
through the chair now i think it's
reasonably self-explanatory
it does include as the as you've
mentioned the
online feedback as well as the hard copy
feedback the cfo and i
put the figures together
so yeah it reflects both
um mr executive do you want to make any
overall
thoughts known around um the online
comment
yes uh thanks worship the only
observation i'd make
is that it would appear that having
three choices has just thrown up
a lot of indecision if you like from the
community because no one option
no one choice or option has
50 approval rating or higher so it does
leave the council in somewhat of a
quandary
in terms of being able to proceed with
any specific option the only one that i
would
quarantined from that line of argument
would be optional would be the first
issue which is
the how we fund the lateral connections
um for stormwater separation mainly due
to the fact that with three waters
reform
now raging upon us it could well be
that elizabeth street is the only street
that the council
will separate before uh it transitions
three waters into most likely another
entity
so it could would be that the council
may be able to
make a call on this
street in terms of how it funds lateral
connections
and with reference to three wars reform
uh can perhaps state with a degree of
confidence that it wouldn't create a
precedent
for any other projects of a similar ilk
but the rest you worship i think you may
be looking down the track of further
consultation
and shaping up each issue with a bit
more definition and going back to
the people of the community
and possibly with fewer options
so you get some conclusive feedback
um council grant the worship um
just personally i i found the
the way it was set out the options a bit
confusing
on on the grass where you've got the the
thirty
the uh the yes the no and they don't
know
if you look at it another way and if you
took the yes boat
and you took out the no and the don't
knows because people
generally when they vote they vote for a
yes they don't vote for a no and a no
they vote for a yes
this is you know my way of thinking
i've gone through and done an analysis
on that and
you're correct on on number one
um steve which is the uh the water
option
um it's exactly 41 versus 41 on option
one and option two and option three is
thirty four
on the library which is option one
transfer ownership to an arts trust is
37
redevelop as an information center 32
demolish and expand as an open year
50 so that's that was a clear
also the rural fund used to reduce the
bridge debt was 43 hughes to fund and
consultation was 38
and retained funds for future was 34.
so i guess there's um
statistics can be interpreted a number
of ways and yeah it's interesting to
hear
your thoughts there i am very aware that
you know one of the issues that we
worked through
as the plan was progressing was with
audit
um around what this looks like so i
think there has been some
it corrected me from wrong some some
quite strict criteria about
how this was portrayed and how it was
analyzed
is that right uh yes you worship there
and i might be able to comment on more
specificity but i can
certainly recall that for example the
option of
demolishing the former library building
was a specific option put forward by
audit to include in the mix it wasn't
didn't come from staff but it's it's
it's a clear winner as far as the
submitters go
yeah i mean and if we're listening to
submissions we're listening to
submissions
and when you put it down on paper uh the
options
there's 50 verses 37 verses 32.
you know so yeah so
renee do you want to make any comment
um thank you your worship the
yeah there's a lot of additional work
that they required for us to put some of
these options in and
to cost a lot of them and it's a
requirement by legislation that that be
done
in an ideal world a lot of those would
have been fleshed out more um
for example with to developing a visitor
and tourism business center you know we
would have done a lot more analysis
around what potential income we could
have
we could have done so i mean there is
there is scope for us to go back and do
additional work in the future and go
back to the community on these on these
issues
if that is what the counselors wish
so so just coming back to the point that
council grant was raising
so can you just explain to me again how
you've interpreted the figures
well instead of looking at the no and
the and don't know
you look at the yes now you you've got
three questions in front
of you but people are asked is it no
well
no they're they're asked um they're
asked to take a picture
box so i was i was looking totally at
the yes
you don't look at the note you look at
the yes but they're asked to tic you
know
as well don't don't agree no they just
know it's just yes
is that right
the the person has an option of ticking
um
taking a the yes or the no for the
various issues
right um and and not every person who
made a submission
actually ticked um every
issue or question either so the number
of respondents for each is not the same
in some instances yeah there's
there's quite a few submitters that that
uh completely left it out right
but but the actual yes is in the in the
um
you know it's it's on the feedback form
and
um if you you take a note you obviously
want to know if you took a yes but you
don't count the whole lot
you wish the for the purposes of
recording
the yeses and no's is it right to assume
that
if for example just anyone if we talk
about
say option two and the first choice
if it's 63.6 percent is listed as no
we are only counting those people that
have ticked that box
we're not we're not including people
that have left no blank is that correct
uh through the chairs that's correct so
say as you say for example you take
um option one for the
um so the the old library so
just looking at the data here um we had
um 79 respondents to that question
and of that 79 we had 24 who tapped the
yes box
we had 48 who took the no and we had
seven who ticked the don't
know box does that help i hope
but i think the point council grant is
trying to make typically when you select
a yes
on a vote the other two are no
that's typical there's one looking at
them there was one or two that
did more than one two yeses or you know
but typically the yes the affirmative
choice
is that the point you're trying to make
yeah 100 that's
that's how you read it and this is i
mean having the no vote at 63
on option one it's just
yeah i was looking at as as i would
think
generally 98 of the people that filled
it out would be looking at it
so we do have clear winners and
a tie on the water and a winner on the
real fun
whether or not hmm
okay so look um
thank you for confusing me counselor
i've got it i've got it all written down
here it's quite science i've got no
doubt
you have see that very scientific
it took me a while too i'm sure it did i
know one or two people who can do that
um counselor bulger
yeah just to help
look i know it's your practice too and
it's the council practice to be very
try to submit and get everybody's points
of view and that's what
council's required to do and i know
you're pretty hot on it but
but somewhere along the line but we're
at the point here then we've got to make
a decision and so
this gives me no clarity at all all i i
take from this is people don't want to
pay
everything and they want the council to
do it maybe it's up to us to make a
decision
and it's sometimes we're going to upset
people but
we're in a position where we've got the
facts we know the long-term view we know
our financial position
we have put our hand up when we stood
for religion to do our best
and i think we should you know because
we
this is one of those ones it doesn't
matter how long we consult we're going
to get
we're not going to get a straight answer
when it comes to connection
so i know i know you'll be taking me
aside after this and saying
not what i wanted to hear clifford but
that's my point of view
okay i think we need to work through
these
one by one um
unless there is a a will by council
to want to do further consultation
because there is a bit of confusion here
that turning it off we're on i'm right
okay um
so there's no no will to do further
consultation i'm understanding
um counselor dixon i'm just wondering if
there is a way to collate
all of this so that we like i know doug
has done that but is there a way that we
can
look at all the uses and knows and
can i ask the communication manager
who's largely
responsible for this i think not
pointing any fingers
um is there a way that you can
um i won't say manipulate
is there as a way that you can present
this in a
in a manner that's got a little bit more
clarity for counselors
um in a word probably not yeah
it's two words right let's um sorry
let's work through them
one by one on issue one uh we're talking
about
uh the funding of wastewater and
stormwater pipelines uh to private
properties
uh specifically in elizabeth street
and just also as we're discussing this
bearing in mind
that we're on the eve of a huge reform
within the three waters delivery
space which would impact on
on this work being done and how it was
funded and
and just before we get into the
discussion um
i wonder mr chief executive if you could
just give some clarity to councillors
around
if there was a will from councillors
to to fund the properties to get this
one street over the line
where would that debt sit once the new
entity had been formed
under the proposals as have been
foreshadowed to date your worship uh all
debt directly associated with your three
waters assets will transfer to
the new entity or entities
that propose to be established
from three waters reforms and the target
date for that
at this point in time is one july 2024
so on that basis your worship are you
looking at say elizabeth street
which we estimate um it's going to take
us a little while because
we have the same contractor doing both
wigan street which is
very much time dependent around the
stimulus funding
so elizabeth street we don't anticipate
starting until
unfortunately in summer and
it logically will be probably
close to 24 by the time the job is all
complete and laterals are
connected so what you it's
i think it's about an 18-month job
overall so
what you're saying i think is that this
is probably going to be
a project of its own and
it would be most likely unlikely
that you would do further stormwater
separation
given that the three waters reform
is will be quite close up close upon you
so you could as i said at the outset
treat this as a
one-off without uh having to
be held to that decision and creating a
precedent that may be
awkward to remove yourself from
thank you okay so in the light
of that i'll open
issue one uh up for council
discussion and direction council bulger
clearly there's got to be a contribution
from the
property owner it's their asset
they own it it's of value to them so
they have to make
a contribution i do think because it
improves
our network the wider community also
which is council makes some contribution
so the options to my mind are
the split between council contribution
and property owner contribution is it 50
50 is it 60 40 is it 80
20 right that's where i think the debate
should and your worship if if there was
to be any
um further consultation i think it
should be around
about what that split is having said
that
we do want everybody to make the
connection around about the same time so
we can organize
some um economies with the
scale and efficiency and so
once again there's another reason why
council should be lead by making a
contribution
look i'll i'll throw something out there
i'm seeing it that's a one-off
and say 50-50 from council in in in the
right part just for the sir
and the property owner just for this
elizabeth street
hook up okay i think it's very generous
yeah look
thank you councillor bulger i think the
rationality present is a reasonable one
other councillors do you want to make
any comment um
councillor phillips thank you your
worship so when this new
identity takes over and
we've gone say for option that
the property owner pays for his own
renewal out to the street and we pay
from
the pipeline back into his boundary and
the new identity takes over
he won't want anything to do with the
private owner
so if we fund the private owner
in the first round where does it sit
with the rest of the property owners who
win the private identity comes in
whoever it might be
and starts renewing other pipe work but
yet those residents have to
end up paying potentially
we don't we can't uh guess what they
might do no
no that's true and potentially we don't
know
that the private uh identity may want to
pay for everything
but they won't because they won't want
to get involved with the private
uh right path yeah and i guess we've got
to be careful about trying to
second-guess what a new entity might
look like and how it would operate
um we've got a particular issue in front
of us now
and we need to make a call on that one
but i hear what you're saying
other comments from councillors
councilman issue worship i'm i'm a
true believer in that the property owner
should fund
fund the his own work from the boundary
in
and that it should just be made
manageable by council by either
an interest-free loan or some sort of
spread payment
over a period of time and that that
tidies the thing up
people are going to take responsibility
for themselves
most of us have got two hands one head
and two legs but we've got the ability
to do things
so let's just people are just getting
too
spoon-fed in my opinion today but it's
too easy just get out there and do it
if you have to save money dig your own
ditch because that's what we did in
ravensbourne
when i was a kid of about 12. we got out
there with my father and we dug the
ditches
so that's what he said okay
thank you um other thoughts
around this particular items nikki yeah
through your worship
i think a new entity would most likely
just go to the street
i don't think they would see their role
as going into the
private property as such either so i
think i take councillor phillips
phillips's view on that and i agree with
councilman macdonald i think
it is the landowner's responsibility yes
we are requiring it of them so maybe we
need to
look at options on how we can um
spread that over a period of time for
the for the landowner
okay counselor hosted i didn't think i
would but i'm actually leaning towards
councillor bulger's recommendation here
we've got a problem
in elizabeth street and on from
elizabeth street so
it's a street that we're not just
solving the residence issue
we're solving communication community
issue and um
yeah probably up at this point i've been
pretty firm on the owner should pay
then read some submissions from some
people who just simply didn't have the
funds to
to make ends meet so while we can sit
here and be
all about fairness um there is a start
reality out there there's a lot of
families
that do own properties that are
struggling to make ends meet so
i think 50 50 is a fair
sharing of cost it is a one-off
we don't know what the new regulator can
do but we need to do what's right for
our community and not be second-guess
what might come so
i'm leaning towards yeah as i said
suggestion yeah i think the point that
councillor heisted makes about a
community-wide issue
this is um this is something that's
going to stretch right across the
community and if we can make a good
start
by encouraging that at what potentially
won't be
an ongoing debt or cost to this council
then i think we should certainly explore
uh those opportunities um
council guard on yes i was probably very
much in favor of them
the private owner owning it and actually
doing the work but then
going forward this is quite a unique
situation
we're actually not going to if we can
roll that debt into the new company
um well it's going to be shared across
the south island basically
and um there is an opportunity to do
that and if you do that 50
well it's going to be a wee bit on the
owner and a wee bit on on the council
but it's actually going to belong to the
whole of the south island the end of the
day
so it probably is only a one-off thing
it's not going to
happen going forward i do agree that
probably the new company will make the
owners pay to the street and no doubt
they will or they'll make some facility
available to do that
and for us to set up a facility just for
one street and then
in 2024 we're out it seems a bit of a
waste
to do all that work and then have
nothing and the other thing
probably more so is we actually don't
have to make this decision straight away
because this project's not going to
happen probably till
2023 and will be a bit clearer
where this new entity sits and what what
the rules will be
and if it's going to go ahead so we can
actually postpone this decision
understand that i'm also
sort of ringing in the back of my mind
that we're in the position
that we are as a town because we've
postponed decisions for
decades but i understand what you're
saying
uh councillor phillips thank you russia
while i agree with brett in the aspect
of about
the right part is finding it finding it
struggling
but i don't think that we should be 50
and 50
because when the new identity takes over
and he does another street
we see the president that we've paid 50
of the right powers boundary line
into his boundary we paid 50 is that
what you you're asking to do
so then do the pain the people then come
back to the council
when the new identity starts on another
street and ask for the same thing
because we won't own the asset
so you know like it's uh i think i think
we're going
down deep deep hull if we if we do do
that
i understand the fears you have uh
councillor phillips but i think that
when that cut-off occurs then this
council
or whatever council is goes forward
won't have a responsibility for that so
i don't believe there is a
a huge precedent being said if we do
decide to go down this track
other councillors any comments at all if
our council hosted so just reflecting on
an earlier discussion around motivation
for property owners to connect um to the
scheme we
we invest in the rain gardens and the
infrastructure in the street
but struggle to get people across the
line to connect under their own
steam would not be a successful outcome
on
other street projects just chuck that in
there
okay um council dixon and then we need
to make some progress
okay look i'm just wondering if we went
50 50 then
and the the council puts in their
funding and the landowner
hasn't got the ability to will we have a
facility to assist them or how is that
going to work because there will be a
lot of people that
won't even be able to come up with 50
well i think it depends on the direction
council takes now if that
if that is a track we want to go down
then that can be part of any
recommendation
so that hasn't been discussed at this
point in time
so um not coming back we're pretending
to go around in circles here
um councillor bulger made
inference that he has prepared to move a
motion
previously he certainly um uh
foreshadowed that
he's still in that he's willing to test
the failing of the meeting by moving a
motion and the connection be funded
jointly between the property owner and
council at a rate of 50 50
right okay do i have a second deal for
that
counselor heisted okay
we've had quite a bit of discussion um
around this particular item but is there
anything councils
want to say before i put the put the
motion council grant
yeah i'm actually quite happy with that
because it's exactly 50 50 on my stats
so you know from what i from the
submissions we should
bang on so yeah i'll agree with that one
okay um right uh
everybody understands the motion i'm
going to put that motion all those in
favor please say aye
against right the motion is carried
thank you thank you councillors and to
count the counselors to vote against do
you want your
vote recorded yes thank you so council
phillips council guardian and councillor
mcdonnell
thank you right
well how are we going to option two um
issue two uh the future of the
old gore library um
so i'm not sure how your stats work on
this one um
do you want to make any comment on this
one
yeah i think this one you uh you worship
i
i really do think it would benefit from
further consultation because
some of the options and as
laurnae has described have not been well
defined they're very conceptual in
nature
and so obviously demolition is
demolition but
if you if you know the estimated cost
versus what the option
of transferring the property into
the hands of a trust and what the
trust's
plan was was for that
it may it may change people's opinion
um and likewise the second option which
also wasn't well teased out so
i do wonder whether this one is
right for further consultation once the
each option has been better defined for
the public to make an
informed choice okay
um councillor davis you think you
worship
there's no hurry with this particular
item like we don't need to break our
necks over this one because it's the
building's just
there and it's not accumulating anything
or doing anything so
we don't have to rush with this i would
be very interested to see
there's been a lot of talk about what it
could be used for i think
we as a council need to see something
concrete put in front of us
and if it is to be gifted to a trust we
need to see
what's involved with that trust and what
the trusts are likely to do with it
i think to just outright demolish it
before we explore those options would be
you need your
reaction and i just think we need to be
patient by their time
see what is presented to us and then
make a decision after that
thank you so are you moving in that
direction
i can move in that direction right i'd
like the second thing
okay thank you council dixon so we do
have a motion um
other councillors want to make any
comment before i put that motion
counselor grant thank you worship um i
actually agree
um i believe we should i mean
uh the demolish on on on my
scientific stats that it demolishes here
is way above everyone anything else any
other option
50 versus 37 versus 32 on option two so
but uh as councillor davis has said
you know we need we just need to hang
off on that that building is not
deteriorating i believe that there's no
leaks in there anymore
um it can be used for other
for other options and not you know
instead of
someone suggested
in their submissions a um gold guitar
museum
could be perfect for that instead of a
trust who knows but you know there are
other options that can be used for so
yeah i'll agree with that okay
uh councillor heisted thanks for
watching i was like
to make the point that that these are
pretty high level options
and i don't recall sitting at this table
and and seriously considering
demolition um as as an option i don't
actually recall discussing it
i realized it was put in as a as a
teaser into the
into the options um and also the other
options
we've we've only really just got very
high levels so it's going to be clear on
that
when we and to me it's not just about
consultation it's about this table
getting its head around
the deeper die on those issues yeah i
think i think council davis is correct
that there is no hurry with this there's
quite a bit of water to go under the
bridge
uh on on a number of uh ideas and
and there are any number of ideas being
floated for uh potential use
council reed thank you worship um
correct me if i'm wrong but
did we not say that that was um put in
there
under request from the auditors yeah
that option
yeah so yeah obviously it's something
that
hasn't really been um discussed around
the table
sorry i'm sorry
yeah sorry lorna that's right yes your
worship um
the discussion around this original
question was actually just to go out to
the public and see what they would like
to do with it
so our option was to go
provide some more information on what
you would like to see happen with the
old old library
the auditors uh came to us and said that
is not an option that that is not an
um item for a consultation document and
you need to have some more options and
there was some costings around
which is why the additional options were
put in in the first place we did try and
discuss with them about it being high
level at this stage and that there
wasn't
a developed idea as such so it was
either
take it out completely or leave it put
it in there and get try and get some
feedback
and in a way of where the community's
well was with it okay look i think
there's no doubt that
uh the committee are interested in what
happens there um but we just need to
take a little bit of time on
and just working through and informing
them what the potential options are
so unless there's any further comment
i'm going to put that motion
all those in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
councillors
right issue three and what should we do
with the rural special fund
council got on yeah quite a lot of
submitters agreed that we should
actually get the rule people together
and get some ideas and i think that's
probably quite a good idea
okay so um further consultation
council bulger i think the original idea
of
paying down the loan on the bridge is
the best idea because
that benefit has spread across every
rural rape
every single one where some of the other
options
may be a bit more compartmentalized so
that's why
i favor that option
council garland yeah i think i agree
with cliff but um i don't think the
public actually know the reason why
we suggested that so i think i need to
explain to the rural
rural public why we suggested that
option
okay so um are you moving in that
direction
against gala so that further
consultation be undertaken with the
rural community
right do i was seconded for that motion
second to council bulger
thank you uh is there any further
discussion
does not i'll put the motion all those
in favor please say aye
against the motion is carried right
so we have um one or two comments
uh from managers um is there anything in
there that counselors wish to
to make any thoughts known on the next
page
no um
right
all right okay so um
the petition that we had
from mountain road
residents with regard to
potential upgrades of that road has been
treated as a
submission and
we have some uh
do you want to make some comment on this
one steve
the main development you worship since
this matter was first
raised and considered by the council at
its may meeting
has been nzta or katahi
announcement of a restriction in funding
which has a big impact on
capital and renewal type funding which
the traction seals would come under
so i just think the council may need to
step
cautiously in this one because some of
the
the comments made in our may report
about the availability of nztf funding
to
to contribute towards the traction seal
part of the job
may not now be applicable with what has
been quite a
severe contraction and available funds
so i'm wondering whether we may need to
explore further the concept with nzta
before the council makes a definitive
commitment to to proceed with the
project
given the unknowns around what it might
be
cost wise to the council to achieve that
okay i understand the limitations that
the funding from waka katahi have placed
on council
and i understand that we need to
understand those
in depth a little bit more as to what
the impacts might be
i am also very aware that there is a
need on that road to
to make it a safe place for for people
to
to access um so yes
let's get a little bit more information
but yes
let's make sure this is a priority going
forward
so i'm opening it for counsellors
for the four-year thoughts councillor
davis
it was a good petition um and i thought
they spoke very well
to it um going forward i'm just
wondering if there might need to be
some level of communication with the
residents so that they know where we're
at
as far as how we're trying to progress
their their particular issue
any other thoughts from councillors uh
councillor gardine heisted dickson
um so basically wakata have carrier
funding for capital works by about two
million dollars isn't it
yeah so that's is that two million
dollars the share of it or
just uh total some
i'm pretty sure that's a global well
actually i'll let lawn i ask that one
so waka katahi have reduced our funding
for the first three years of the
long-term plan by 1.4 million
there is an additional it's a it's a
weird mix of how they've done it they
have actually increased
some funding operational maintenance
funding particularly around rural roads
however air capital funding has been
decreased significantly so it's 1.4
million
over over three years
i actually submitted on their plan that
they put more money towards rural roads
so it's your fault yes but that's
um uh probably i think i think it might
have
had some influence i don't think it
would have because basically they're
just short of money
that's counselor guard on uh counselor
hi said sorry
you thank you i was just looking at the
recommendation of the
of the meeting following the discussion
with the petitioners and
and it was requested that we receive a
report on the whole of road solution and
i guess we're not in a position to do
that
just yet but i think that's the crucial
piece of information we need before we
go any further yeah and but i think in
the short term
the petitioners need to be made aware of
the restriction that's been placed upon
us as well
councillor dixon you wanted something
coming oh you worship i i just
i'm reading the submission i know that
some of the concern is about
the blind corners on that road it's not
just all about
sealing um and it would be good to have
some
council to have some input into that and
perhaps look into
how they could um make that road less
dangerous
okay so um is it correct me assuming
that there is a will
um to address the issue that's been
raised
um but we just need to um advise the
petitioners that
there has been a change in circumstance
with regard to funding availability and
we need to
spend some time working out what a
solution looks like
going forward is that is that the way to
progress this
would somebody like to move in that
direction councillor davis thank you i'm
a second defender
just another comment i'm happy to move
it though i'm thinking um
we may need a working party on this
particular one especially with the blind
corner situation
might require a little bit of input from
councillors as well
yeah look i'm more than happy for uh
councillors to come together
yeah so does anybody else want to
speak at this point in time council
garden
probably just gotta be a little bit
careful when you drive around the rural
roads
um there is more needy roads yeah look i
think there's
everybody's got their own particular
circumstances and and personally i was
quite surprised
and i shouldn't have been because i've
been up there a few times but i was
quite surprised at the
the level of development that's happened
in a particular
small area on on mountain road and
the issue that that is creating so
i think we just need to give ourselves a
little bit of room to
develop a solution that's going to be
successful but also fair
in terms of the the rest of the rural
network
councillor mcdonough the the ceiling of
the road was
what we referred to when i've talked to
the people on the mountain road is the
cream on the cake
but there are several pieces of the road
that need attention
just for safety there's some pinch
points on the road
particularly at the bottom end where the
seal joins onto the gravel
and there's some water problems when
it rains water coming down the middle of
the road so there needs to be some
work done there so there's maintenance
work to be done
and if there was money then they do the
ceiling but we needed to
attack these little maintenance jobs
that are probably in the water ten
thousand dollars or
no i'm not enrolling so i don't know but
i don't think they're massive jobs but
i just got to deal with those first
right
um okay so there's still a will around
the council table to
make a difference for these people
advise them situation
put together a small working party to
connect with them as
as we get more clarity around where our
funding lies
and work out a good solution you're
happy to move that
nikki dove a second for that councillor
reid thank you
uh all those in favor please say aye
against the motion
is carried is there anything further
that we require to
um debate or give clarity to
staff on with regard to the long-term
plan
nothing okay so in terms of
the next step um
the motion that we need to to move at
this point in time
do we need a an overall emotion
um no i don't think so worship you've
you've actually taken move and seconded
during
the process you may you could have a
what i call an omnibus resolution to say
that
the staff be authorised to make
amendments to
the draft long-term plan to take
acknowledgements of the decisions
made today and that the finalised plan
replete with office of the auditor
general's clearance
be submitted to the council for approval
by the end of this month
okay look i'm i'm happy to move in that
direction
do i have a second for that
second to councillor mctinnell thank you
is there any further comment that
counselors would like to make does not
i'll put that motion
all those in favor please say aye
against the motion
is carried thank you councillors for
your contribution today
i think that has been a very orderly
process through the
submissions and while not everybody will
be totally satisfied with the council's
response look i think we've um we've
handled each one of the submitters in a
fair and an appropriate manner so
so thank you for that but there is no
further business on the agenda so i'll
declare the meeting closed and
wish you all good afternoon thank you